5 que vous allez jouer dans le court
métrage d'eric entre mathias et maxime
un simple baiser menacent de tout faire
basculer
pour les amis d'enfance cet événement
sous site une douloureuse remise en
question avant tout matière c'est maxime
est un film sur l'amitié pour moi mes
amis c'est ma famille ma famille sont
mes amis
pichon un peu amoureux aussi de mes amis
c'est sûr que j'ai pas la vie
sentimentale la plus la plus abondante
la plus la plus fonctionnelle et puis
j'ai trouvé un très grand réconfort puis
un grand équilibre une stabilité aussi
dans l'amitié ses coûts et à l'écran
xavier dolan s'est entouré de ses 13
années
d'habitude tu deviens une famille sont
un vrai tournage rende devenus une
famille nous on était déjà un peu donc
je pense qu'en effet tu aimais tant avec
cannes avec le tournage je pense que ça
peut être juste en effet peut-être
renforcer nos liens encore plus ça se
peut xavier nous a dit qu'il fait mine
jeudi qu'ils pensent à nous déjà et
becquet xavier qui va des scènes et nous
lui faisons tous les élus de l'amitié
pour xavier c'est touchant comme de la
complicité entre la troupe crève l'écran
des acteurs d'une grande justesse qui
voulait lui plaire quand lui sans qu'il
a atteint ce qu'ils voulaient atteindre
et tout le monde le cpie ses comptes
ajoute veut absolument retrouver cette
réaction la chine tu veut lui redonner
quelque chose qui va le rendre heureux
dix ans après j'ai tué ma mère xavier
dolan retrouve sacré midi elle fétiche
et joue à nouveau son fils jamais je
donnerais à rendre le même personnage
deux fois c'est pas intéressant pour
elle puis je la connais comme actrice à
me connais mon psy comme à tapis je sais
que ce qu'on recherche c'est à être
quelqu'un d'autre pays à se transformer
le réalisateur prouve une fois de plus
qu'il sait raconter sa génération avec
sensibilité nuance intelligence voici un
bon dolan qui ne décevra pas ses fans de
la première heure ici nabi alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal